It was the all American boy,
handsome,
smart,
charming.
In fact,
theodore rubbish Bundy was the stereotype of what every American boy or to be
like and what every American parents wanted their son to aspire to you.
Above all,
ted Bundy was charming.
He had a winsome way that could in people.
Yet this same college wunderkind snuffed out to the lives of scores of beautiful
young women.
He was a charismatic killer,
who's Jacquelyn hype.
As soon as we're so vastly different that he fooled his closest associates for
years,
many of them would still not believe that there Ted could commit to the
atrocious crimes that were piling up alongside his name,
even as the evidence became overwhelming,
he made a mockery of law enforcement running rings around their attempts to
catch the world's first serial killer.
Bundys brilliant minds made him a master Predator with his abductions being as
well planned as a military action.
He has gone down as the most infamous serial killer in US history today,
decades after his execution in the electric chair.
He is held up by many as a macabre celebrity.
The poster boy for mass murder.
His story is a paradox.
In his past,
there were no signs of the deviant behavior that would manifest itself in an
insatiable bloodlust.
He wasn't in fact,
on track for a brilliant career on the other side of the law as a prosecuting
attorney.
His performance in his own defense showed what a great promise that Korea had
held upon sentencing Bundy to die.
Judge Edward o coward summed up the feeling of so many new ones were affected by
Bundy.
It is a total waste of humanity that I've ever experienced in this course.
You are a bright young man.
You've made a good lawyer.
I'd have loved to have had you practice in front of me,
but the UN's another way,
Patna.
As we examined Bundy story,
we got closer to answering the question of why he chose the way he did,
but then again,
even with this analysis,
we may never really know.
Just before we get started with the biographics video today about Ted Bundy,
if you like this sort of dark stuff,
definitely check out friends of the channel.
There's another channel called criminally listed.
Go check it out.
You'll find a link to it in the description below.
Loads of Daca,
stuff like this on that channel,
and let's get into it.
He adored Robert Bundy,
was born to 22 year old element Lewis Cowl on November the 24th,
1946.
His father was a sailor who'd never hung around to meet his newborn son when he
was four.
Ted's mother,
who was told was his oldest sister,
took him 3000 miles away to tacoma,
Washington to live with other family members.
Ted was heartbroken to be taken away from his grandfather with whom he had
developed a special bonds,
although no one ever replaced his grandfather and his affection Ted scene became
close friends with his two cousins,
Jane and Allan Scott.
Meanwhile,
his mother was making a friendship of it.
Ryan Elena was now going by the name of Louis.
She joins the methodist church and seemed crossed paths with a young man by the
name of Johnny Colpepper Bundy.
Johnny Bundy stood five foot tall.
He was a cook and came across as a shy and reserved kind of guy,
but newies sensed that he was kind and dependable.
Soon Raymond said blossoms after a well winds of methodists,
social functions.
Louise and Johnny were married on May the 19th,
51.
The family bought a home there,
narrows bridge while Johnny kept on working as a cook.
There we use 10 heads to secretarial work.
Children followed two boys and two girls as he grew up.
Ted was often pressed into babysitting service.
He willingly complied even though it would usually mean missing out on outings
with friends.
Although the family dynamics were stable,
ted was to grow up in an environment of untruths and uncertainty.
He was still being fed the line that his mother was his sister and his
grandparents.
Whereas actual parents during his years at high school,
he ran with kids who had connections whose parents were either rich or were big
wigs in the school environments.
Ted could never match up,
and as a result,
he was often teased where others were out giving.
Ted came across as shy and reserved.
Ted never warmed up to his father in law despite Johnny's acceptance of him and
attempts to build a relationship.
When Johnny became a scout leader and organized camping trips that we usually
find some excuse as to why you could and attendance and adolescence.
Ted grew rapidly,
but he found it very hard to put on muscular size.
He was too skinny to play football that we did join the track team at hunter
junior high.
However,
it was a classroom rather than track and field where Ted felt most comfortable.
He maintained a b average,
taking his schoolwork and homework very seriously.
Ted graduated from Woodrow Wilson High School in Nineteen 65.
While he was making solid progress academically,
he was also beginning to build a reputation that was not so favorable.
He had already been in trouble with the law in relation to some petty
burglaries.
It was also proving himself to be an unreliable worker.
After graduating high school,
10 began working for Tacoma city light.
His plan was to attend college and the enrolled in the University of puget sound
for the 1965 to 1966 year.
Twelve months later be transferred to the University of Washington in Seattle.
He began living on campus.
There's a dormitory room.
It's mcmahon.
Hold,
I think University of Washington,
Ted's winning personality began to manifest itself.
He was charming,
well dressed,
and came across as educated.
It's professors force.
He was a brilliant,
studious individual with enormous potential deads charmin's good looks,
made people see beyond the emptiness that was as cool
it was during his freshman year at Washington u that tat first fell in love.
The object of his desires was a beautiful,
dark haired girl that lived nearby.
She was,
as he would later describe how the most beautiful creature he had ever seen.
He found out her name was Stephanie Brooks from a distance,
tad martyr,
studying her like a specimen under a microscope.
He stared at her in the lunch room,
fantasizing from afar.
It seemed,
became apparent that Stephanie was into the football jock crowd and Ted became
despondent despite their differences.
That was one thing that Ted and Stephanie had in common.
They were both skiers dead thought that maybe this was his enemy showing signs
of overcoming his insecurities.
So you took the bold step of asking if he could hit you with her to the ski
slopes east of Seattle.
She readily agreed.
Happy to have some company,
and thus this began the start of their unlikely romance,
the pastor who's spending more time together,
Stephanie.
It seemed to enjoy his company and sought him out as potential.
He had become besotted with Stephanie.
Soon they will love us.
Stephanie was 21 to 20.
She was from wealthy California stock.
He was a legitimate.
She grew up in the midst of money.
He didn't have anything yet.
That relationship worked and they went steady for the next year.
For Stephanie With Tad was an enjoyable extended fling.
She was in love with him.
Sure.
That's not in the way that he was with her.
She had known from the start,
but the relationship was never really going anywhere.
That spend some time together,
enjoy themselves,
and then go their separate ways.
After all,
there was no way that tends to fit into society.
Stephanie's graduation in June,
1968.
It seems like the opportune time to end the romance.
She'd be moving to San Francisco to find work.
While Ted stayed on in Seattle,
a finished his studies to say that Ted took the rejection from Stephanie badly.
Could be the ultimate understatements.
He was absolutely devastated.
Grime author and rule who worked with dad on a Seattle a crisis hotline,
believes that the breakup of his relationship with Stephanie was the catalyst
for everything that followed in Ted's life.
Ted could not accept that the relationship was over immediately set about
finding ways to weave Stephanie back.
He also immersed himself in law and politics as if to drown out the agony of
losing him.
Ted's despondency spreads through his academic life.
The ones brilliant students was now struggling by the fall of 1968.
He to crops are completely off.
Several months following in despair.
He re enrolled at the University of Washington,
taking papers in psychology that included deviance,
personality,
and deviant developments,
throwing himself into his studies.
He impressed as professors as an older student.
He was truly gifted despite his rigorous study schedule to have still found time
to frequent the bars of the university district.
In September of 1969,
the handsome laughable.
A young man called the eye of a woman named Meg Anders.
They were both alone at the Sandpiper Tavin.
Ted made the first move asking if he could buy her a beer reluctance of first,
she was soon one over by the Ted Bundy chant before she knew that she had given
him her phone number.
10,
and Megan began spending evenings together and Megan quickly came under Ted
Spell,
falling deeply in love with him in a sense this was a reversal of Ted's
relationship with Stephanie Mag,
adored the ground that Ted walks on,
yet it was less committed his mind often on other things and other people.
He was still pining for Stephanie,
but meg would do in the meantime.
Nineteen 69 and 1970.
We're stable years in the life of Ted Bundy.
He was focused on his academic progress,
impressing his professors and gaining qualifications that would lead to his
chosen legal career.
The relationship with meg was steady and he was playing the part of surrogate
father to her young daughter.
Leanne did this with passionate joy.
During 1970,
[inaudible] was awarded a commendation by the Seattle Police Department's when
he ran down a snap snapchat.
A few months later,
he saved a drowning toddler at green lake.
Tend to pretty much transformed herself into the all American boy.
Now,
at the beginning of 1971,
ted took a part time job at the Seattle crisis clinic situated on Seattle's
Capitol Hill.
He did the 9:00 PM to 9:00 AM,
shift a few nights a week on a Tuesday nights between 10:00 PM and 2:00 AM.
He was partnered with a 39 year old part time crime writer named and rule for 10
months.
They work together,
the crime writer and the future serial killer.
They worked tirelessly to help solve people's problems.
On many occasions,
they even helped save people's lives.
That was an amazing counselor.
He was always calm and he had an aura who is voiced that put people at ease.
He reassured he guidance and the entertainments and empathetically listens.
In April of 1973,
ted was awarded the position of Assistant to Ross Davis,
chairman of the Washington State Republican Party,
along with the job,
came a $100 a month salary use of a credit card and expenses for travel.
We're paid by this time.
Dads had been with meg for four years.
Their relationship,
it was steady,
although it often felt like meg was doing more of the giving than Ted was still.
He was excellent with lists all leanne,
who absolutely adored him.
Marriage seemed just over the horizon for the couple wants Meghan didn't know
was the ted still carried an unquenchable desire for Stephanie Brooks even when
he and meg when making love.
It was Stephanie's image that was present in Ted's mind and so it was that when
he flew to San Francisco and the Republican Party business trip in the summer of
1973 to rob tendons,
Stephanie,
they went out for dinner.
She was bowled over by the changes he had made.
Now he was sophisticated.
He was confident.
He was in control and it appeared he had money.
Ted's plans.
He winter,
overworked perfectly ends on partying.
She agreed to come and see him in Seattle and she did just that.
During how awesome vacation Ted took Stephanie to dinner at the home of his
boss.
Ross Davis introduced her as his fiance.
Then he whisked her off for a weekend in the snow.
What a cascade.
Poss.
He had books a luxurious come to for just the two of them.
Over the course of that weekend,
Stephanie fell in love with Ted all over again.
When he began talking with marriage plans.
She excitedly joined in future plans for a life of domestic bliss.
We're made of course,
neither Stephanie Nor meg knew of the other's plans to marry Ted Bundy,
often his weekends with Stephanie.
However,
he began to evade talk of marriage with meg.
He seemed to be getting very cold feet towards the end of 1973.
Ted Managed to coordinate is to love lives so that he could wine and Dine
Stephanie more liberally.
He brought her to Seattle and they dined at various restaurants throughout China
town.
Strangely,
the Stephanie was sensing that something was different.
It was becoming less affectionate.
He stopped talking about marriage plans.
He confessed that he had been having an affair with another woman and that she
had ended up having an abortion.
He was becoming cold,
clinical,
and uncaring towards Stephanie.
He didn't even buy her Christmas present despite our attempts to get to the
bottom of his strange change in attitudes.
Stephanie was unable to discover why Ted had become so cold to water.
He simply wouldn't let her in.
When she flew back to San Francisco at the start of the new year,
Ted appeared to be glad to be getting rid of her.
Stephanie waited for Ted to reach out for an explanation as to why he attends,
but it never came.
In February of 1974,
she phones him angrily demanding an explanation.
He simply hung up on her hands with that,
Stephanie would never again speak to tat.
During the first six months of 1974,
eight women went missing from college campuses in Washington,
Oregon,
and Utah.
When you look at the photos of these women,
you can't help but be struck by how much they looked alike.
They all had small frames,
long hair that was parted in the middle,
and what good looking every one of them resembled Stephanie Brooks.
As the case files mounted.
The killer left no trace.
Investigators were surprised and immensely frustrated.
The demand could commit such brazen abductions and leave absolutely no trace of
evidence in its wake.
Indeed,
each attack would be slightly more brazen than the last.
The adapter would snatch girls who were in closer proximity to others almost as
if he was daring anyone to stop him.
Located at the southern end of Lake Sammamish and King County,
Washington Lake Sammamish state park.
It covers 512 acres and features 6,858 feet of waterfront.
The level landscape features buttercup filled pastures and is dotted with trees
in the summer of 1974.
It was a popular bathing spot and sunning spot for thousands of local residence.
Lifeguards patrolled and it was a range is hot on site.
On July the 14th,
1974 legs and Hamish was packed with excess of 40,000 people who were eager to
make the most of the glorious summer weather.
Among the throngs of Sunseeker is on that day was an attractive woman who was
sunbathing by herself on the beach no sooner had she settled into a tanning
session.
Then she looked up to see a man towering over hat.
He was wearing a white t shirt and jeans and his right arm.
Was it a cost?
Excuse me.
I'm sorry to bother you.
He began.
I was wondering if you could help me out.
The gold looks over at him.
He was good looking and seemed somewhat nerdy to happen.
She didn't sense any danger from him.
Help you out with what she asked.
He had knelt down beside her and explained that he needed to launch a sail boat,
but couldn't do it with this cast on it.
He offered to take her for a ride in the boats and he was exceedingly charming.
Yes,
she would go with him.
She said as they were walking to where the man said his sailboat was.
He offered his name tat it was about this time that the girl got cold feet.
She begged off saying that the parents were waiting for her to other young women
of the leg that day.
They weren't so lucky.
Twenty three year olds jenise often to 18 year olds.
Denise Naslund winds along with Ted's and were never seen again.
Ted had dramatically onto the stakes.
Not only had he freely given his name to a potential victim,
but he had approached at least six women on that Sunday afternoon in broad
daylight.
Clearly he was feeling invincible.
There was nothing that the bundling law enforcement officials could do to stop
him.
He was far too clever for them police.
They were able to produce a composite sketch of Ted based on the statements of
the eye witnesses.
This was circulated up and down the country.
Three thousand 500 tips poured in from the public.
The police compiled a list of potential suspects.
Name Ted Bundy.
His name was on that list,
but it has more than 2000 people on it.
Ted's moved to Salt Lake City on Thanksgiving weekends in 1974 to attend law
school.
Immediately secured a job as a security guard at the university.
The initial focus of the Utah killings,
it was one of the small towns that lead within the vicinity of Salt Lake City.
They began on October,
second,
1974,
the victim with 16 year olds,
Nancy Wilcox.
She disappeared from holiday.
A small town just out of Salt Lake City.
That so you could walk to the store to buy some gum,
and she was last seen by an eye witness getting into a light brown Volkswagen
bug tabs next to the 18th.
This time the victim was the daughter of the Midvale police chief,
Louis Smith,
the third Utah victim with 17 year old Laura Amy from Lahey,
25 miles south of Salt Lake City.
It was October the 31st Halloween night.
Laura was a high school dropout who had moved out of our higher minimum with our
friends,
bought at the lack of action that night.
She had left a local cafe just often,
midnights and proceeded to walk to a local park.
She was never seen again.
Less than a month later,
ted abducted an 18 year old girl from a local mall by impersonating a police
officer.
Fortunately,
she managed to break free from his call moments after he had slapped handcuffs
on one of her wrists,
a frustrated Ted's drove for another 17 miles before coming to the humans
highschool where a school production was in progress.
You have dr and killed 17 year olds.
Debbie Katz in 1975 though 10 founders and you killing zone Colorado.
It he murdered at least five women during a six month period.
Burying best skulls in a bizarre graveyard in the Taylor mountains
in the early morning hours of August,
the 16th of 1975.
The police finally caught up with Ted Bundy,
a minor traffic violation.
They do a search of his car,
which produced a burglar's.
Kits,
competes with handcuffs and rope.
The authorities were seeing able to connect the dots and charges of aggravated
kidnapping and criminal assaults were brought against him.
He was found guilty and sentenced to 1:15 years for the police.
This was just the stars.
They now set about building a case to hold you accountable for the trail of
bodies that he'd left in his wake.
Dad was adamant that he would defend himself in the upcoming trial and was given
access to the Aspen Law Library to do research during a visit to the law library
on June the 17th,
19,
76 months.
He managed to use the power of a second story window.
He went straight for the local river bank.
He took off his courtroom outfits to reveal a second set of clothes underneath.
He then brushed himself off and calmly walks back to the center of town.
That was the police rushed to set up roadblocks.
He wiled away as time browsing in stores.
It was classic Bundy.
After a week on the rung,
he was recaptured.
I need to break out again.
Six months later,
this time,
he was able to evade,
recapture,
and set out for Florida.
He set himself up in the vicinity of Florida State University.
For over a year,
he managed to control his urges until on the night of January,
the 14th,
19,
78,
his demons were unleashed in an orgy of violence that left to girl's dead and to
mall,
hardly decent at the Ci Omega Sorority House.
Over the following weeks,
Tad continued his rampage killing a 14 year old girl and attempting to abduct
another was the girl,
the daughter of a police detective helps police produce an identical picture and
is that along with a series of mistakes on Ted's part,
led to his recapture around February the 15th,
19,
78.
This time,
there would be no escape.
After a lengthy trial in which he defended himself,
Ted Bundy was found guilty of murder and sentenced to death and the electric
chap,
he spent a decade appealing.
The decision was finally executed on January the 24th,
19,
89.
By that time,
the bundy phenomenon grown with legion of mainly female fans who would fall in
love with tess and wrote passionate love letters to him.
It seems that they conveniently forgot,
but he was one of the most cold hearted killers in history,
so I'm not going to ask whether you enjoyed the video,
definitely of our darker ones,
but if you did find it interesting,
please give it a thumbs up below.
Also,
if you're looking for more great content like this,
there's another channel I'd like to recommend.
Their friends have this general end of top tens as well,
that cooled criminally listed.
You can find a link to them in the description below,
so go check them out.
Also see some of our videos from the archive over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.